the man who is a Emmy award-nominated
host again for College GameDay on ESPN
and who will be hosting the ABC coverage
of the NFL this week
Reese Davis of ESPN great to see your
brother great to see you too it has been
a real long time since you and I have
seen each other obviously you've called
in the show but it's been a long time it
has been a while I think we saw each
other briefly at the Rose Bowl
yes couple years because you were kind
enough to try and get my kids down to
the set it just did not work it was 100
some odd thousand people there are a lot
of people cool about you know the thing
is our friendship goes back so far that
certainly excited about hosting the
draft coverage on ABC and forgive me I
don't is it tomorrow and maybe Thursday
afternoon yes when you Trey and I are
going to be on together and I was like
looking at that and someone said is that
okay and I'm like I'm on with Eisen yeah
that'd be great it's been a long a long
time
three o'clock local time here I guess 5
o'clock 4 o'clock Eastern just before
the pick that's gonna be great I won't
talk about that in a minute but it's
just been a long time since I I've
literally seen you and it's it's a
pleasure that's why I'm I saw you
sitting out there and like come on in
let's be you're a broadcaster of the
first quality let's uh let's just hang
out and have a news update brought onto
Kris Brockman go ahead and hit it with
the news yes and it's brought to you by
my friends at the Honda dream garage
spring event where a great deal is
available on the Honda of your dreams
waiting for you whether you need
versatility or you want to drive with
the latest and greatest tech there's a
Honda that is right for you so head into
your local Honda dealer today what do
you have yeah guys you got our first
trade of NFL draft week the Seahawks and
franchise defensive end Frank Clark to
the Kansas City Chiefs for a 2019
first-round pick that gives Seattle two
first-round picks in this year's draft
and a 2020 second-round pick in exchange
thrown picks this year according Adam
Schefter Frank Clark and the Chiefs will
now finalize their long term contract
that's it right there Frank Clark from
the University of Michigan back in the
day and I think a great pickup for them
because you're not getting you might get
a player who has as productive
eventually but you're not getting
anybody proven like that right but were
the Chiefs were these
a great tree I mean all it's a great
deep pass rush draft for sure but you're
not getting one of those top flight guys
down there at 29 and we were talking
about the end of last hour I mean you
take a look at how you build NFL teams
right now and what you try to do if you
can is win in the first contract of your
stud quarterback who has either burst on
the scene
unbeknownst to what you were hoping for
or like mahomes or even brady back in
the day but now if you can win right now
in mahomes as years before he makes 40
million annually mm-hmm you got to do it
right now and it makes sense to just go
out and build your team right now and
and Patrick Peterson is saying all sorts
of fascinating stuffs on on Instagram
it's he's cryptically instagramming out
that snakes in the grass and which would
lead you to believe that he's on his way
out of Arizona but then other people in
our business are saying there's nothing
there
that he is staying put with the
Cardinals I don't know why would he be
instagramming snakes in the grass or now
instagramming photographs of guys who
have left the team were no longer on the
card right Tyrann Mathieu among others
do you remember time Ries when we did
not glean or look into things and
people's Instagram everybody reacts to
Twitter we go oh my god writers reacting
we got to do something else yeah which
is probably why at the collegiate level
where you do much of your bread and
butter mmm all these coaches tell kids
just you're not on it
we're just not letting you on it anymore
a lot of them do and they're much more
circumspect but I think that's because
there are repercussions for them if they
tweet or in-store and you can't do that
in the Pro it's a different deal which
it's a rare thing that a guy in college
and if he does people scream captured
then he's taking it down and then you
know the SSID comes out so I didn't
really mean that you know we just saw a
guy who's made it to the Oakland Raiders
and it has the richest contract for a
rod receiver annually in the National
Football League
using insta
Graham and Facebook and Twitter to get
out we just had his cousin right here in
studio now if you if you cross paths
with Marcus I did not see him this time
I've really dealt with him a lot he's
got a quick first step as you know yes
it's hard to stay in front of him I
really liked him he as a player as a
young man yeah he's a terrific young man
for sure and I like him as a player just
because the way the game is going with
with his speed on the outside he's got
unbelievable speed his story which it is
just remarkable he was operating rides
at Six Flags because nobody wanted him
out of high school went across the
country paid his way for JUCO and now
here he is and he's gonna get a chance
in the NFL yeah Six Flags yeah Six Flags
otherwise known as a dead hockey Lee
first quarter fortunately for the NFL I
mean what other everybody's retiring and
there's a lot of new official I know
well maybe Doug Marrone should have used
Instagram to get in touch with Jalen
Ramsey how did you hear about this story
an excellent segue by the lanky sir I've
learned from the best so of course we
heard about Jalen Ramsey not showing up
to Jaguars volunteer workouts Doug
Marrone did get ahold of him didn't have
his phone number so he didn't get back
to him right away he texted the wrong
phone number for Jaylyn Ramsey did a
fight did finally talk to him said they
had a great talk he's training here in
Nashville geo and Ramsey is with his
brother spending time with his family
he's going to come back in the best
shape he's ever been he's all fired up
so it sounds like it's all hunky-dory in
Jackson know what I'm saying Doug
Marrone didn't have the right phone
number Doug Marrone texted the wrong
phone number for Jerry so does that mean
there's somebody with whatever area code
phone number he has it just looks down
at their phone Lansing
who the hell is coaching I couldn't
figure out what was going on the person
who received the text was the person who
received the techs have been a big fan
and decided not showing up
I want to go to the Browns mr. pink
might call me mr. big chest oh man you
know in confluent - did you see complem
was asked about this he's like I'm not
commenting it on it anymore and that's
again it's interesting cuz Coughlin is
from a different era as we all know and
I said he should be in the Hall of Fame
for everything that he's done for the
Giants and obviously the Jaguars as well
if the jaguars get back to the suit get
to the Super Bowl and he gets back to
the Super Bowl with them that then right
well shouldn't you agree yeah okay
probably already I agree with you right
with two rings with the Giants and then
what he's done and then if you want to
talk about the total of football as well
Boston College I mean we could talk
about all of it but he does have a
mentality that's a little bit out of
date when we're talking about offseason
workout programs like this is why the
NFL Players Association says we need
time built in where you cannot touch us
and you cannot require us to be there
and to say what he said I think created
a little bit more of a stir with jaylen
Ramsey and you think about it it's a
different time and I think coaches or
former coaches who are you know in the
front office now have to accept that
players are in better shape now if this
is not the old days where you bring them
in to get them in shape they already in
shape right they're an unbelievable
condition year-round all the time you
have to trust them a little bit if you I
mean they've got the ultimate trump card
you can demand it you can cut them you
can release him it's different than
baseball
so guys are motivated to stay in shape
and they do I think for the most part I
know but I just cannot believe the
cookie yeah that's great last night on
Twitter know I saw one or two of his
tweets and I'm like I read through a few
and got bored is that bad I was like
yeah okay you know every Bodell just had
fun kind of firing back at people who
are accusing him of being a cancer in
the Giants locker room questioning why
he didn't travel with the team when he
was injured and so Odell just just kind
of fired back a couple of the reply
ask any one of my teammates who I was a
teammates and a man and a person yes I'm
a cancer to a place that's okay with
losing because I want to win that bad
you're absolutely correct so kind of
little sarcasm back at this guy
also we didn't sign him to trade I mean
put in quotes you don't get married to
get a divorce I tried my best a
situation I had been in since I got
there never changed you don't get by by
the way we should set this to country
music that sounds like a doesn't that
sound like a country song I didn't get
married to get divorced we're in the
right place so we should set we should
set the you've got a great staff here
they can do we should set the odor that
Mike doesn't that sound like a country
most lyrics come on I mean that's cowboy
country songs don't you think yeah we
should consider cross coming in on
Thursday should we have him perform
bringing gels sounds like a music learn
I didn't get married to get divorced
yeah that's like a thing and now you
don't let me hang around with and the
song is called I proposed to her kicking
net Chris I didn't get married to get
divorced is is sort of the the the I
guess companion to Dave gentleman at the
combine I didn't we didn't it's not him
to trade him right I didn't get married
to get divorced we didn't kiss on I mean
this is like a slim Whitman's greatest
hit you can see you can just see the
title scrolling through your screen yeah
I could understand why you read through
that thread and you're like okay yeah
after a little while it was like got it
that said though I think the worldwide
leader has several Cleveland Brown games
in the first month of the season did to
Monday night airs in the first five
weeks I think yeah I think so there
they're gonna be a hot team they're
gonna be a team that's drawing attention
I mean Baker Mayfield has that charisma
I was all on board with him taking him
number one I understood the limitations
much like Tyler Murray but Baker's got a
certain it factor guys are drawn to him
and I think they're gonna be very
successful obviously upgrading the
roster with Odell and some of the other
moves there's gonna be good look and
we're gonna talk calamari in the next
segment with you but Baker I had me at
hello yeah when he planted that flag in
Columbia and so for a team that wants to
change the culture I'm like okay this is
this makes sense I was actually standing
on the sidelines when he did that and I
was like yeah but you watched him sort
of part this yeah what were you thinking
I was I was thinking is he really going
to do this I mean he you know that's I
thought it was I don't have a problem
with that kind of stuff and maybe I've
I'm an old guy but maybe I've evolved a
little bit the celebrations you kind of
there are certain things that can be
disrespectful certainly in a pregame and
I know a lot of people did have a
problem with it but to me he didn't like
that even though it's a tradition he
didn't like that they sang their song
the Buckeyes the previous year when they
wore him out on their field so he
answered with his and that's okay
that's part of it you know and just the
fact that they're probably so many
Browns Buckeye fans hated him and then
suddenly loved him one of my favorite
draft moments that I would fortunate to
be in the chair for was when the Browns
drafted Jabril Peppers and they took the
shot of the Browns party of the fans and
they were all high five and each other
Mike where've you been last year just
makes strange bedfellows what would you
be mad at me if I said they weren't too
mad at Jabril because I think a quarter
of their defensive staff they just took
from Michigan right now yeah they did
it's um some of the guys yeah Greg
Madison well that's one of that's one of
the things that we've sort of filed away
for next season you know not speaking to
them trade or all of that kind of stuff
while still giving Madison props because
they appreciate how he helped them
develop but yeah it's strange but
they're not strange all right you got
one yeah couple more things that
the way this is very fast so the Chiefs
have agreed to terms with Frank Clark
already five-year deal 105 million
that's sixty sixty three and a half
guaranteed I'm Todd they're they're
going for it right now and if they can
get Patrick Peterson I don't care how
many draft choices it cost them just do
it now mm-hm you got that offense their
remarkable they're only gonna get better
because they're so young you can
supplement it with third fourth fifth
round picks
mahomes is two more years before they
gonna have to pick up that fifth year
option which is it you know a chunk of
change
not like what he's gonna about to make
go for it right now that's how you win
in the NFL do it any you know you know
much more about the NFL than I do but I
think it's the biggest fallacy and pro
sports right now is is building for the
future it's this it's a different era
when you have an opportunity you better
take hamstring the Sixers in the NBA
they're almost an exception to the rule
because all these teams you try to you
know hoard all these draft picks it
doesn't work out most of the time right
and I I'm all fo as the sport where you
can go from four and twelve to twelve
and four in a season well I think just
to bring it all full circle here and
then we'll take a break and come back
with reason is that the Browns though
have cashed in on the draft choices that
the previous administration left for him
yeah that's true and but they but they
they went ahead and got an old hand and
John Dorsey to cache those picks into
human beings like took the steering
wheel away from the people who were
money balling their way yeah into what
we're seeing right now yeah and that
they're they're actually going ahead and
turned them into real human beings that
can play football which is exciting and
it just it's so great to see you man
rece Davis and so I'm gonna have a fun
conversation with you I can't wait to
have a talk with you about you know what
your career has become and what we used
to do together and how in a way for
hopefully I'd love for that segment to
be more than that six minute or
something like that on sure well I mean
you've got to talk to them and say we
got a take on the show three hosts
together we're all used to having our
hands in this
I don't know how the hell it's gonna go
down it's going to take a few minutes
for us to figure it out yeah let's be
honest here you got three control freaks
with microphones like who's gonna ask a
question of each other right it'll be a
lot of fun we'll chat with more with
rece Davis when we come back here live
before he anchors the ABC coverage of
the draft from Nashville here in a
moment welcome back to the Rich Eisen
show okay welcome back to our show and
in studio with me here for it with me
right to my right is is the host of
College GameDay and a longtime friend I
would say I know that when when I left
ESPN you know a lot of people grow apart
cuz you don't work together a lot but
rece Davis I always consider you true
blue you're a good man
and I'm pleased to have you here on the
show thank you for for joining oh he's
glad to be so Chris I know if I ever
told you this story okay as you know I'm
I'm a 26 year old man yes hired by ESPN
out of Redding California just showed up
and my my head was spinning and also I
was a single man I you know I hadn't met
Susie had my wife and and I was invited
over to someone's house for Thanksgiving
in 1996
no one that I had no place to go pretty
much my folks were down in New Jersey I
couldn't get down there cuz I was
working that night it was you and your
lovely wife Davis my wife Lee who made
some southern dishes and Turkey and we
do always do for me I got married while
I was still working in Flint Michigan so
which I tell you you want to test true
love although I loved my time in Flint
about six weeks before our wedding I
took a job in Flint Michigan and she's
like I'm not sure this is my decision
right but fortunately it's worked out
for us well ten days before I got
married to Susie ESPN and I parted ways
that quickly Reese Reese I didn't know
that Reese let's put it this way I got
married on June 7th 2003
I got a letter faxed to me this give you
an idea fax to me from ESPN saying we're
done two days before it was all over and
before I could even figure anything I
was out somebody from USA Today called
up to ask me my comment about quote
unquote not getting renewed when I
thought we had 48 more hours to just
negotiate so I this is a new story to me
I mean friends I never knew this story
let's put it this way there was an
executive table at my wedding with some
empty seats it was interesting I didn't
mean a trump I mean no no no that that's
we both had some interesting stories to
tell the surrounding our wedding with
with careers you know and Susy was
living out in Los Angeles as a
broadcaster she came back to New York
cause we were gonna live together and we
wound up being in Los Angeles together
you know again months later at the NFL
Network and you know and that's why I'm
being very honest I'm very excited to be
on with you and Trey on Thursday because
you know I I'm I did an appearance on
Mike and Mike I think on espn2 mm-hmm at
a Super Bowl I just appeared in a spot
and it just was simulcast there mhm and
when Stewart passed
Scott Van Pelt had me on via remote
I remember seeing sports yeah which I
was touched by that he would reach out
to me and he Espeon would would want me
part of the remembrance of such a
special guy yeah and we both have great
stories of just hanging out which stew
and yes you you know you I came a year
after and you were I'm sure part of the
The Deuce era with that stew that's what
I was hired to do was to be on that show
with Stewart and Susie an hour
our kids are close to the same age in
fact our daughters graduated high school
together same high school same high
school yeah both went to Miss Porter's
school in Farmington and graduated
together part of the same class so you
know we've maintained friendship with
Kim over years - and you know Stewart
was a great friend and
talents oh yeah of course and you guys
had unbelievable chemistry on the air
well before he and I would just open up
our our schedule you know they would
just put the schedules into the computer
Chris back in the day and it would it
would happen at any time during the
movie
yes seriously like you're trying you're
trying to figure out what your life is
for February and it's like January 10th
and there's no schedule out and we would
always look at each other good is a
schedule and so before you know and you
would just open it up and Stewart and I
just started realizing why are we doing
the show together more often than not
we're fine with it but like are we a
team now because we if we're team we
want to be announced as a team like
Keith were a team right and if you
weren't part of a team you were like
looking at each other wondering like how
can I get part of a team describing
exactly right I mean and you always
wondered when you would open up that
schedule every month if depending on the
shows you got even though the executives
would deny hope I don't get in trouble
saying there's but probably guys anyway
they would tell you I doesn't mean
anything and you absolutely do meant
something yeah something you know I know
but before that you and I did a ton of
sports together when I first started you
and I would do a ton of them late night
you and I spent many 3kms waiting for
some Colorado Rocky reliever to get a
strike over the plate and 14th inning
right like the great producer Rob
bizarro who used to always said we would
have to wait because the show would
Riera
18 times right so you'd have to wait
till the final game was over right and
you would hear Robbie G get your ear
some time ago the Dodgers have been put
on this earth to screw me but also you
know Stu and I would definitely go off
script a ton and Rob gujjar you mean Rob
G would be producing all of these and so
we would go off script
and we would just blow the timing of the
show totally out of the water
I was mindful of it Stewart I think was
mindful of it but didn't care he was
just doing his thing and as you would
say doing it and doing it and doing it
well yeah right and so I knew we were
happy as they say in the business our
run down was being blown up and we'd get
to the commercial break and we'd wait to
hear our instructions for the next
segment about what would what would live
or die as the phrases and the run down
from Rob and then he'd get in our ears
and the first thing I hear is he
wouldn't say that we're killing him
either like the doc oh I'm so glad we
had the same experience while we were
living it at the same time and anyway
the reason why I bring it all full
circle he's at I have not been on ESPN
since I walked off the set on that
Sports Center that night that I had no
idea was my last mm-hmm like literally
did not know the night I've walked off
my last SportsCenter that I'm leaving
and that everything about my identity to
this point where I met Susie I met my
wife our three children our ESPN babies
hmm essentially because of that it means
a lot to me to be back and with you who
I've known for a long time and Trey how
three sticks Trey Wingo it's gonna be
great like it really does mean a lot to
me that that in the partnership that the
NFL is created for the draft with you on
ABC and Trey on ESPN and me on the NFL
Network that we do have a spot for us to
chit chat like that I'm really looking
forward to it rich I think it's I think
it's appropriate I feel very sorry for
the producer of the show and and okay
great I think she's going to be with us
some kind of so so feel sorry for her
get the mic back but although yes
although I think that might be you might
get some really intelligent television
with four hosts on
because we are the most crucial part of
a broadcast it's without us it falls
apart I'm sure you do the same thing I
tell my producer on gamedays Rodney
Perez with a live production things can
go wrong right and I'll always tell him
I say hot rod you get in trouble brother
put that camera on me and we good my
story in regards to that
rece Davis here on the Richard the show
is I tell all analysts on the NFL
Network and we have a ton of athletes
who just come off the field and before
their careers are over want to kick the
tires on the paparazzi want to kick the
tires on their career cut their teeth
and their bye week or what-have-you or
in the offseason or step off the field
and they're hired and they're suddenly
an analyst I tell them there's always a
safe word when you're in trouble and
you're on live TV the safe words are
back to you rich so a perfect example
we're at st. Thomas Aquinas High School
in Fort Lauderdale for the Pro Bowl I
think Jesus is now a 10 year old story
because it was the Super Bowl with the
Saints and the Colts where the Pro Bowl
was no longer annually in Hawaii they
were gonna have it on the mainland
whenever they could so they had the Pro
Bowl before that Super Bowl and we're at
st. Thomas Aquinas high school for the
practices and we're live on the NFL
Network and Maurice jones-drew
who was playing at the time was our
correspondent for the NFC practice
because he was playing in the AFC so
when he wasn't practicing he was a
correspondent for us doing the
interviews for the NFC so I told him the
safe word before he go it's me I think
it was Marshall and Dion on the set and
Maurice we send out into the field and
we're live listening to his interview of
Frank Gore mister you mmm back in South
Florida it's his time he's on the 49ers
he's interviewing him and their hunt
live TV and he asked him like what are
you doing here and and you know back in
Miami it has got to be good for you back
here in South Florida and he starts
talking about hanging out with his
friends and he invites him to go hang
out with him
script club and me Deon and Marshall
start screaming you know and that's
nothing that was were kind of going back
and forth here about the past and the
present that I I'm thrilled to be able
to say this to like where you say you
raised your hand back when we were
working together and you're like hey out
like why couldn't you be on a team why
couldn't you get that opportunity as I
would think frequently well I wanted
that chair when Keith left it for Dan
Kenny got it and it was fine with me and
Stewart and Stewart will always be upset
with me like why do you want to go do
that show just were teens yeah
whereas if he caught that chair he would
have Terry himself like that that's the
that's the way that it was the dynamic
we we liked each other we respected each
other but it was a little competitive to
see you in the position that you're in
right now and getting the a mean arms
and I hope you win this year it's so
great you totally deserve it well thank
you I appreciate totally deserve it
and it's so difficult I'll say one last
thing to be the guy after the guy fowler
hosting College GameDay
stupendous and the show has not skipped
a beat well it's gotten more popular you
could even make the case of right now
well thank you me Chris Chris does not
believe of course host it's an all time
no and he he helped build the foundation
and and make gameday what it is in terms
of being part of the landscape of
college football it's a little bit of a
unique show I think because it's not
just a pregame show it's part of the
experience of the college football
Saturday and Chris had you know a ton to
do with that and you know he and I spent
a bit of time talking we're we're not we
don't know each other that well you know
but we spend a lot of time talking some
of the meetings and so forth before then
but I've been very grateful for the way
everybody you know you've used the word
team they've accepted me as part of the
team because the competitive spirit was
there with the guys who were on game day
previously and the guys that I had in
the studio over the years you know with
mark
Lu and before that Trev Alberts so you
know there was some there was some
competition there much like you
described with you and Stewart and so
for them to accept me has been great and
you know I I didn't find that
SportsCenter team like you guys did but
I had that I had my basketball guys I
mean I've been I've been on TV with
Billis for 20 years you know he's
amazing there's no there could be no
better teammate in the world because I
still print like a typewriter like his
handwriting is like I told him he said
when we work together there should be a
Billis font yeah yeah I can't believe he
still does that
bilis and Jesse Palmer tiny precise
kidding unbelievable printing and fun
yeah I would never guess it about Jesse
Jesse Palmer's notebook on football I
mean because of all of the varied
interests and varied things that he does
right that guy's so unbelievably
prepared when I did Thursday night games
with him he would have carry a notebook
around with him of handwritten notes
about everything he sees very meticulous
so reparation is that rece Davis here a
few minutes left with Reece on the Rich
Eisen show so is the ABC coverage gonna
essentially be a college gameday but
instead of it being on campus you're in
Broadway and instead of it being talking
about a college game you're talking
about an NFL Draft is that essentially
bad yeah I think that's the feel of it
rich it is going to be it is going to be
player player driven and what I mean by
that is that we probably not that will
ignore this but we won't spend a lot of
time talking salary cap or how a guy
might fit in a team what moves they
might make as a result of taking this
guy we'll be talking more about the
player what's the team getting personal
background stories anecdotes that we
have from having covered most most of
these guys on campus yeah especially the
guys who will be the first couple of
nights oh we all we know them all and
you know we'll we'll share those types
of antidotes there'll be plenty of
football hardcore stuff but it won't be
it won't be driven so much by why the
Seahawks will part ways with Frank Clark
you know what if they haven't done
something by then what the Cardinals
might do with Josh Rosen obviously that
will come up organically but it'll be
more about the players themselves yeah
and
it's Corso gonna put on the headgear of
each team on the clock
the Jets hat on when the Jets are on the
clock or what is he guessing that at the
game day show because we have a game day
pre-show as well that'll be on ESPN at
the end last year he put on the Mel
Kiper head but we'll see if we can get
him to be maybe it'll be a little braver
this year and actually and actually make
the video felt we'll give you 32
different headgear that would be great
let's do before every pitch you just
prefer the Jags are on the box
forget the bear making gambling picks
the bear will be part of the broadcast
hi I've told you this when you when you
were kind enough to try and get my kids
down on the field knew it was just such
a cluster at the Rose Bowl
shocker Rosanna and we got stuck behind
the Oklahoma band which was great was
amazing that wasn't gross the Oklahoma
Georgia was a team is in the NFL yeah
they balled out last year Sony Michelle
for crying out loud could have been the
Super Bowl MVP right but any rate the
fact Chris FeliCa the bear was in the
init was in the Sports Center and ESPN
I guess research pen for years for years
and so Susie and I know him from years
when he was Felipe's you know from just
talking about the you all the time
because he loves a team you see him on
TV and my kids love the bear they love
when the FeliCa got that camera and
right in his face like like he's at an
ATM machine and it's that you know like
it's boom like right there in front of
them they can't get enough of him
you know her he's a star he dies he is a
star and his rapport with Kirk who by
the way you know with Herbstreit who be
a huge part of this guy has such
unbelievable feel for television and
when he when he kind of gets her a
FeliCa know I'm talking about her okay
alright Herbstreit as unbelievable feel
for television and knows exactly when to
wind the bear up and he's so good at it
and he'll he'll he'll look at me
sometimes in he'll go start nodding his
head like that encounter California I'm
like okay he's ready to why the bear up
on something so I could
it'll be fun there's the now I'm looking
forward to Thursday from from from
everything it's gonna be a big night
real quick
Kyler's Mari who is he I think what can
you tell me about him knowing him it's
been such a question mark certainly from
the NFL evaluators about who he is I
think the best story I can give you rich
is he's obviously he's not the outgoing
dynamic charismatic guy that Baker may
feel was that make that comparison
obviously the Heisman same school first
pick potentially and all of that stuff
but he is fiercely competitive he and he
he plays with probably because of his
size he almost lives with a chip on his
shoulder I was at an event with him I
don't want to say which one because I
don't want to embarrass the people
involved in his name was mispronounced
and this was after he won the Heisman
and I sort of you know wind up to him
and said just it's okay let it go but
you could see him bristle and this was
not in a bad disrespectful way it was
just sort of you know he has worked hard
for the recognition he has gotten and he
wants to be appreciated for that way so
he he did he doesn't let things like
that go I think it serves him well in
terms of being quarterback and a leader
and you know I think they're probably
still a lot of people would tell you
there are some things that he could
still work on in terms of getting guys
to gravitate to him making sure he's the
first one in as quarterbacks need to be
and all that kind of thing it you know
it got him in a little you know many hot
water for not starting a game missing
being a little late a couple times
things like that but they're minor I
think he said really I think he's a good
young man he's an engaging guy when you
talk to him it's been well trained he's
under sized everybody knows that but
he's a is an uncanny athlete and I think
I think he's worth the shot I'm not
gonna sit here and tell you for sure
that I am as convinced as I was about
Baker but I do think if I had to pick
one way or the other I think he'll be
successful I didn't know that story
about his name being mispronounced and
that means Dwayne Haskins is the only
Heisman finalist whose name was not
botched throughout the entire month of
December yeah
my gosh can we can we can we get to his
last name right as you're announcing him
as a potential Heisman Trophy winner
Reese it's great to see you I believe
since obviously Berman did all the
drafts and Trey nor I as other hosts in
the NFL Draft have ever done an NBA
draft you're probably the first who's
going to host an NFL and NBA draft in
the same year is probably true
so probably Congrats on that as well
that's fun great to see you brother
thank you likewise you got to thanking
the right that's rece Davis check him
out on ABC when the picks start dropping
right here in Nashville for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app